what's the deal with airplane
peanuts from Haunted comedy clubs like
the comedy storees haunted right but
know that to sleep paralysis demons the
ghosts have been acting up lately these
are the spookiest ghost stories told by
comedians starting off with the story of
Gus the ghost well so in the ' 50s The
Comedy Store used to be a club called
zeros and it used to be the hottest club
in Hollywood but it was run by the mob
and during the days people would get
killed in the where the main room is
you've been to the comedy store right so
that used to be the showroom and there's
these if you look up on the ceiling
there's these little openings up above
where you people would snipe you know I
mean people wow wow so I guess a guy
named Gus died there one time when car
laau and Sam Kennison moved to LA from
Houston they they snuck in the store to
sleep cuz they were poor right right and
they slept on the main room stage and
carlot he passed a couple of months ago
God bless him and leau um tells a story
where he wakes up and he sees Sam
kinerson being levitated by his foot and
he's like 3 feet off the off the [__]
but kenon asleep still yeah right but
here's something that I witnessed
There's a comic by the name of Pete
that's his real name I don't to say his
last name and he was in the belly room
he performed have you been in the Green
Room at the in the belly room yes okay
so from the the showroom to The Green
Room there's a little hallway you walk
through right this dude's like my height
right if you look at the ceiling it's
pretty high it's probably this High the
way the ceiling is Pete has a good set
in the belly room walks down the hallway
and then his head hits the ceiling he
gets thrown up in the ceiling he breaks
his [__] spine what yeah he's now has
to go through surgery for ye years in
fact he sued the store and he got some
sort of of compensation that's who I've
never seen that this guy before before
after this event wow but apparently you
know what I mean I was there downstairs
but apparently people that witnessed it
right saw him just being thrown up there
like Gus it's Gus in fact me and Johnny
Sanchez who was a comedian back in um
2002 maybe 2001 we were in the parking
lot of the store and we saw Gus for the
first time we both saw them we're in the
parking lot we had dropped one of my
cars off to go do a gig in Bakersfield
and when we drove back it's 400 in the
morning I'm getting my car we're saying
goodbye whatever right and we both look
at the window up above on the parking
lot and we
see a white face a top hat two hands on
the window looking down down on us like
this right and we and Johnny and I go
like like that right and we we then we
look at each other we look up and he's
gone who holy [__] that's the first time
I saw Gus oh my God so I don't you if
you notice I don't stay there past
midnight it's crazy man like even the
ghosts are passed at The Comedy Store
I'm not I'm not pass that was the first
time when was the second time I was
playing the piano at 4:00 in the morning
so it's completely dark and I'm playing
with my own improvised little you know
Korean
L
Ding and I look to my right and I see
the a a yellow suit with a top hat but
from far away you know where the
entrance is I see it coming toward me I
run out that back door you know that to
the hallway and I come back in it's gone
and that I believe that to be my second
encounter with Gus if you if you hadn't
had one ghost experience I don't think
you're human I've never had one I've
never had a ghost you never had you've
had one I mean seen a ghost yeah no no
no not see a ghost I mean a ghost how
about how about an I don't even know the
right wording but like an experience
with an apparition a ghost a a
supernatural the unknown like you can't
explain it like what's one that you've
had my buddy Tyler the when I growing up
I used to sleep over his house all the
time because we would get smoking what
was that no what you Andrew it's time to
be honest in 202 we play mini flutes oh
mini flutes okay so we play mini flutes
all night and uh no but his house the
people that the old the people that his
mother bought the house from they died
in the home this old couple and natural
causes in the home natural causes wasn't
a murder suicide well they killed each
other at 98 years old imagine that 99
Mur Mur bang
bang she's said you'll never make it to
a 100 you won't either Bang Bang boom no
so what happened was is I used to sleep
in the basement all the time and
upstairs was a uh the kitchen had two
Galley doors you know Galley doors that
hide inside the walls galle doors you
couldn't close them quietly if you tried
everyone that has one in their home
knows or you ever grew up with one
they're
like they're so loud right so I'm
sleeping downstairs and I couldn't sleep
I was tossing and turning and the house
always did have this like very ominous
Vibe it was like tucked into the woods
just always felt just very dark and
shady and and you can't really see
anybody around you and so I'm I can't
I'm tossing and turning I can't go to
sleep and I hear the galley door to the
kitchen so I think oh T Ty's mom must be
awake like me like maybe she's going to
get a late night snack and I was like
I'll get some food cuz I'm up and I'm
hungry and I couldn't sleep so I walk
upstairs and the doors are all closed
and I was like it was seconds it could
that's impossible like it literally
couldn't have happened there's just no
way so I go in there and I'm like
whatever I get in the kitchen I grab
like a you know like a candy bar I go
back downstairs I'm eating I hear it
again and it's distinct you know it when
you know what it is it's not like it
could have been something I know what
that sound is I have one in my house now
I hear it again and I immediately put
the candy bar down and I'm like Mom cuz
I would call his mom mom I was like Mom
nothing mom I walk upstairs again and
the doors are all still closed and I
swear to God on my life I was freezing
cold right I felt ice cold and I get I'm
sure that's just anxiety it's all in my
mind but freezing cold oh dude I was
freezing it was freezing cold and I was
like give you a blanket I and and I
wanted someone to wrap me up but but I
swear to God I felt so it felt just so
ominous that it was like someone was
toying with me it couldn't have been his
mother because that her room to get back
to her room sh she could have never made
it there all the way down the back
hallway without me seeing her cuz I
walked right upstairs afterwards so I
was freezing cold and then I went
downstairs and the rest of the night I
just stared at the stairwell and all I
was waiting for was to see something or
feel something but I just couldn't sleep
my brain was just staring at this omin
it just felt so like something was
happening but I just couldn't go back up
there then so do you believe that it was
like I didn't see anything but the
feeling was disgusting I couldn't even
tell you what it was what your spooky
tail spooky tail dude so last night I
wake up it's 3:00 in the morning no
that's the scariest hour pretty scary
dude isn't that the witching hour yeah
dude wi an hour I'm up Maya wakes up
pretty standard stuff so I go down I you
know you do the thing where like
sometimes they put themselves back to
sleep which is nice cuz they do
sometimes you're like yes and then some
well you hear them cry and then they
pass and they pass back out so it's like
some so I'm laying there I'm playing the
monitor sitting there like laying
chilling and then it's like you get like
2 minutes of quiet you're like right on
and all of a sudden it's you're like
[__] so I go downstairs it's spooky as
hell I go down lay with her for a little
bit kind of fall asleep a little bit she
passes out I go and I'm building this
all up because when I disrupt my sleep
during the witching hour and go back to
bed around like 4:30 it's sleep paral
this time almost every time oh man dude
so but I like it I'm a sicko dude yeah
but what type of sleep paralysis are we
talking Visions no here's what happens
to me so I don't pull myself out of it I
know it's coming cuz when I'm laying
there it goes I get these like and like
I can't explain it but it doesn't it's
not like a brain shock a brain zap but
it's like a it's just like Sensation
that like goes it'll happen then like a
minute later it'll happen again it
starts going faster and faster and
eventually I enter the sleep paralysis
tunnel where it's like I'm [__] up I
used to get scared and I'd pop myself up
out of that lately I've been going into
it yes let me tell you that was a spooky
spooky experience dude what so when I
whenever I go in spooky skeletons s
sending shivers down your spine yes dude
this is what happen whenever I like when
you first go into the sleep paralysis
it's nothing but like the spookiest [__]
possible I went into it and it was just
like and you see like the scary [__] I I
was like I can't breathe and I'm was
laying there just
like and all of a sudden I'm like oh
thank God I woke up I'm still dreaming
what type of stuff did you say just like
SC I always see like scary figures now
this is in your room correct this is
eyes closed I'm completely it's it's
like my eyes are closed I can't open my
eyes I can't move like scary fa like you
know those masks people put on there
like a big scary it's like [__] like
that scary faces and like it's like
weird Figures it's it's this is all with
my eyes closed yeah and I have opened my
eyes before and seen it in my room for a
second more so like the shadow figures
shadow figures are the scary guys
spookiest I used to I see them in three
I always have three that's a very common
thing yeah it's crazy did you know that
was common no I didn't know yeah the one
guy in the documentary season three
really usually one guy's wearing like a
top hat yes dude and it's [__] big
Square shoulders Top Hat dude so dude so
I'm is spooky that I knew that the guy
in your dream wore a [__] hat that is
[__] up isn't that [__] scary that
was the first time I had I like woke up
and was in my room but hallucinating
with sleep paralysis that was the Hat
man that was with his two [__]
minions dude he is two minions right on
either side of him yeah man it's so
scary what the [__] is that dude I don't
know [__] I don't know it's it's got to
be [__] but see that's the thing is
so like if you want to talk about like
it's some weird thing that's deep in
every human that it's like we're all
scared of snakes this is what we think
about why the [__] would it be wearing a
hat that's hats are relatively new when
it comes to human evolution in our brain
yeah probably genetics but like top hats
are pretty new yeah dude that's not
something our ancestors would have also
thought of you know what I mean yeah
it's [__] up what the [__] is this
thing dude you're talking talking about
the collective unconscious these are the
archetypes that are built into the the
base of the human psyche so for some
reason dudes in top hats with two with
two boys three Bros coming right at you
three Bros one clearly the boss two
without it's so scary so I'm laying
there d i I go with it I'm like all
right cool I I pass like the scary spot
and this what I get Inception to where I
I'm like oh that was weird thank God I
woke up but then what happens is I'm
like the the thing rattles me so much
that I lose my bearing so I wake up and
I'm walking around my room and I'm like
man I can't can't use my feet that well
and I'm like the [__] going on and
like I and now I'm in like a totally
different place I don't realize I'm
Dreaming I'm just walking around like a
different house and there was like three
kids in a bed and I was like Hey guys
and they were just completely different
kids and they were
like and I was
like I start getting like super confused
like where the [__] am I and I'm walking
around it was that and I'd wake up oh
thank God I'm awake and I'd walk out of
my room and back into some weird setting
I did this like five times last night
within it was like five successive
dreams and then finally Britney tapped
me with her foot and I was like okay
cool I'm in my room well you must have
been bro I was fully I was fugged
hey I'm sorry as you were kids who are
these kids it's kind of cool though cuz
you finally come back dude it's like
wake up dream wake up dream and you get
like really disoriented and you come
back too I was I had a glow all morning
I was just like man this is you're so
happy to Bey to be back in life you're
happy to be back dude in this Dimension
you're seeing me right now after a full
buffal I'm stay in Buffalo right so I'm
staying there I'm the it's the first
night and I'm I'm sleeping there I'm
trying to sleep I can't sleep I think I
was going through a breakup at the time
I had a lot on my mind but um I was very
uh
Keen to the idea that there was like a
presence or something in the room it
just seemed like there was something in
the room and it was freaking me out and
I couldn't sleep and I was like this is
ridiculous you're being crazy it's just
because it's a huge huge room sometimes
you even talk to yourself out loud I do
that yeah you're in a huge room you're
going through an emotional there's no
ghost in the room and I'm just like I
feel like something's in here but I've
never felt like that I don't scare very
easily with stuff like that you know I'm
a big horror fan like it just I was like
this is weird I've never experienced
this before something unsettling exactly
so then the next day uh I wake up and I
go downstairs to the to the front desk
and I'm going to go out and get
breakfast or whatever and I'm looking at
the you know so they have the r back of
the things in the hotel of like the
pamphlets of where to go where to go and
then I noticed like explore the caves or
go on a a fan booat ride yeah and then I
noticed they have pamphlets for the
hotel history and I pick one up and the
first thing I say is famously haunted
the hotel you're in yeah and I was like
holy [__] man that's weird so that is
the extent you felt something you it you
felt uneasy you felt weird you felt a
presence you walked it up to whatever
then the next day you realized that you
were in a haunted hotel yeah and I
didn't know that beforehand that the
only but I guess like the TV light was
bothering me and I remember like I
pulled the blanket up to like this much
so I'm just like laying there and it was
only like a matter of a couple of
minutes I was wide awake and I thought I
heard someone say something now here's
another thing my door to my bedroom was
closed okay I always Clos my door
positive it was closed I'm positive it
was closed and uh 100% positive I closed
it every night I also closed the door
whenever I take a shower and I also lock
the door when I take a shower because of
murderers and Killers absolutely so I'm
not sure if it was locked but it was
closed and I pulled it up and I thought
I heard someone say something not the TV
um as a matter of fact I had lowered the
TV right before the TV was very low if
not muted and I was like getting ready
for bed and so I didn't shut it yet
because I still like the glow a little
bit to for me to fall asleep so I
thought I heard someone and like one
person not like TV like a person say a
couple of sentences and I'm just like I
didn't think anything of it I'm like
maybe I didn't low the TV all the way
but then I heard the door okay and I'm
like I'm just but I wasn't really like
I'm just laying there just like not
really thinking I didn't like hear it
like slam open I just heard movement
movement right and then I felt I just
felt like somebody was in the room I
just I don't know how to explain it I
just felt it I heard some words I felt
movement and I and I felt like like I
maybe felt heard someone walking it was
carpeted but you just felt
it and I I was I didn't think anything
of it like I didn't think certainly I
was getting going to be attacked by a
ghost or anything like that or anything
I didn't know what I was I and then but
then a moment later I really did feel
like someone was standing above me I
don't know how to explain it but my hand
this hand was since it was under was
only thing not under the
covers and I'm telling you right now so
someone then went like this held my hand
someone something I don't know what I
felt my hand get grabbed and then it was
being held and then it got squeezed a
little and then squeezed a little more
and squeezed a little more no I swear to
God to the point where I felt this kind
of pressure on my hand this by the way
this is real pressure like he's like
squeezing your hand that's what I felt
on my hand so in my head you're
paralyzed with fear paralyzed paralyzed
and this all happened I would say in a
matter of 20 seconds but in my head the
first thing I thought of again super
fast was okay someone's holding me now
so what I just thought I heard someone
say something or walk in here is true
and they are standing above me and
they're trying to see if I'm sleeping or
not I didn't think it was a ghost I
thought it was a home invasion right and
I said I have to make sure that I'm
awake right now and I'm not dreaming
this and I was I was like I am I am
breathing I'm looking around I am awake
right now someone I'm the pressure on my
hand is is getting even more and I think
what this person is testing me to see if
I get up and who knows they might stab
me Club me shoot me or I don't know
what's going to happen but what I did
was not react to the squeezing and I
just made like I was still sleeping and
I said what am I going to do right now
and it let go and I said the only chance
I have right now if this person is
standing above me is is if I surprise
them and jump up and be ready to fight
for my my life right I'm thinking this
under the covers yeah and in
milliseconds in milliseconds I said I'm
I'm awake I'm 100% awake I know I'm
awake I know I'm being squeezed right
now I thought I heard something I guess
someone standing above me it's either do
I might get killed right now that's what
I thought and I just was you know fight
or flight thing and I just was like I
had to count to three right now and I'm
going to jump up and fight for my life
and even had the idea to get into the
closet cuz I had a little Yankee bat in
the closet that I kept that they give
out on like bat day I had like a Yankee
bat in the closet I knew it was there
and I'm like I'm going to just fight and
I'll go for the bat and I counted to
three and I said I'm going to swipe the
covers off and in one motion stand I
screamed at the top of my
lungs I do the covers off me I leaked up
and I'm on my bed and nobody was there
nobody nobody was there and my door was
closed and I was like yo hey babe this
and my TV was on and I flipped the light
on and I was like did they walk back out
and I got the bat I swung the door open
and I just screamed and ran inside my
door was locked my lights were off
nobody was in my house nobody so what I
did was I went into the living room
turned every light on and stayed up for
the entire night after that of course
because I was like if this is a
ghost it was a ghost I guess I don't
believe in ghosts but I don't know what
it was spear I don't know I don't I put
you this way I don't know what it was
but that happened to me I want to
believe in ghosts yeah I don't but I
want to I want to you know what I mean
it's just exciting it's fun it feels
like there's Limitless ghost experiences
and encounters from people yet there's
never like a ghost like why wouldn't
there be a ghost experience right now
it's always alone alone I'm upate I got
a creepy old house cuz ghost they got
unfinished business yeah yeah yeah but
the ghosts have an experience they're
procrastinating they were
procrastinating their real life and
they're taking it out on me like I don't
give a you unfinished business should
have finished it while you were alive
pal you know what I mean would you would
you be like so so you think ghosts cuz
then there's religion like where a
ghosts like like just Spirits hovering
around and we don't believe in in
religion and that that's what's
happening with ghosts you understand
like what is a ghost like will you
become a ghost and if you became a ghost
well here's my issue with ghosts they're
only they only look like that they're
only from like the Victorian era they're
only from like like the 1800s yeah like
why can't David Boe float through here
yeah exactly there you go a favor like
Mike drop
it yeah but why that harambe
just so you know I was wanted to live in
Los felis right so I fell out of escro
in a house I was up there and then you
know we're driving this guy's driving
it's like two hours on [__] you know
cuz working in Santa Monica and I looked
on truly on there's a house perfect
[__] most feel like a perfect house
like you go oh my God call this lady I
said hey Brook can you get me in there
she calls she goes tomorrow we're in
there at 1:00 I said there nothing
earlier no no she goes George they have
it like every 15 minutes with a
15-minute break like everybody wants
this house so I said oh [__] then why
you even go she goes hey just go look so
I go in there beautiful pool thing
that's in there and you go upstairs come
down the guy goes what do you think and
I said do it's great and he goes you
want it I said what do you mean do I
want it like what about all these [__]
he goes He I'll call the guys that own
it call owner he's a doctor he goes he's
a huge fan of yours so I said hey guess
who's in your house and he said oh
[__] George he goes hey tell him if
he gives him the full price he can have
it and and there's like 50 [__]
offers wow so I I I paid the full price
and I got it and then you know you do
some work to it and in the fireplace so
my name is George because of I was born
on April 23rd and at the General
Hospital over there my mom wanted to
name me Anastasio who they thought my
father was and my grandmother's like
[__] him you're not naming that
[__] somebody that disappeared
so my grandmother goes what's today
tells the nurse what's today April 20
what's a day it's St George day so she
goes George Edward St George and I told
the dude that I uh the contractor I said
hey man can you [__] clean those
fireplaces out cuz they look like they
haven't been cleaned in forever and when
he calls me back he goes hey when you
get home look in the fireplace because
there's a concised door tile in there
and it's a tile of St George
W from the
1920s so you almost feel like it's I
mean you know it's not St Christopher
it's not you know the being water loopa
it's a [__] St George tile from the
20s so I made the mistake of
calling people especially one who had
just recently passed and that's when a
lot of the activity came a lot of the
banging and a lot of the orbs and a lot
of the [__] but then it was in a
hallway I'll show you a [__] video
there's a [__] person in the
reflection of a picture that's moving in
the thing oh my God but I took a I took
a picture like I felt here's you can see
kind of a shadow I'm I'm I'm going show
it to you but you guys see the shadow so
when I'm in bed now all of a sudden all
of a sudden there's more things
happening more you know like you just
you're like [__] God I feel like
[__] somebody's over there so now it
started to happen on the right side of
of the where the bathroom's over there
and I would go like this
and I'm like so I took a video of that
right side of my bedroom and I didn't
see any orbs or anything but in the
picture not a mirror in the picture I
see this square and I go what the [__]
is that and then I I pull it open and
it's a [__] green
face oh my
God oh my God oh my
God oh my God [__] green it's a green
face green
face and I said I said [__] this I said
I I hired this lady to come and [__]
take him out and she did how would she
um what you say take out the green guy
she no no they know they know [__]
yeah hey the green guy's gone the
[__] dude hanging out of the in the
the m is gone that was some crazy I have
questions now did we did we do the
cleansing in the hippie way or the
Catholic way um I think no I think they
did it the hippie way with the with the
sage cuz that [__] don't work you got to
[__] it I'm sure they're on their way
back but no no listen I know they're on
their way back but
but bab bab but when you see that you're
you're like I don't give a [__] so in in
in these dreams I know that there is a
actual ghost in the room Shane called it
sleep paralysis but it'll hold me down
and at times at times I've had these
dreams where a ghost will hold me down
and have sex with me wait what is that
that's exactly what it is yeah why sleep
par paralysis makes you ghost yeah yeah
there it is I've had it where it holds
you down and then and then it [__] you
and then my first my first nocturnal
emission I was being held down by a
ghost and it [__] me beautiful older
woman I was younger older woman dark
hair kind of looked like elvar like big
breasts got on top of me I was in my bed
she pressed my arms down to my side and
then got on top of me and I had a wet
dream I was probably 15 years old and
then she got up and I woke up and I was
like I just got raped by a ghost yeah I
got raped by a [__] ghost and I was
like and I want that happening every
single night every night I would allow
the ghost adventure ERS to set it up
yeah I would go I if you had a haunted
hotel with just haunted by [__] and
then you could just [__] ghosts every
night I'd do it in a heartbeat yes does
the ghost like dirty talk to you or
anything no it's silent okay the way it
should be yeah just no one says a word
she just comes in [__] me and leaves
yeah let's talk about how you made a
ghost try to kill himself for a second
time by the way I think D Ro would be
the perfect candidate for future ghost
oh yeah oh God you in ghost form
Everlasting just like complaints
complaints oh that's great that's great
wait a minute is that a sitcom it might
be a
sitcom Jo Joe's when Joe's a gohost he's
on boo he's
boo he says it
differently listen it's the ghost of the
Rosa
boo
boo wait a I'm telling this is hold on
this is a sitcom And the tagline of the
poster is Boo Boo has several
[Music]
meanings Joe the ghost Boo has several
meetings coming to
FXX fall 19 or 20 what you would haunt
like an Italian
restaurant mommy mommy there's a ghost
in our room scaring me with
negativity
I started crying and it told me to shut
up told me to grow
up why is the whiskey bottle always are
you drinking in the house no I swear it
wasn't
me at joke
World it
world and the world is
wld that's a great uh YouTube channel
joke World check it out